imagine it's 2005 and you're sitting in
your college dorm room after a long
night of drinking 40s you're about to
log into world of warcraft your exams
are done and now it's time to [ __ ] up
some yetis with the guild view and your
friends made you're a [ __ ] but you
quickly run into a problem in order to
take on Wow's biggest raids you need
more people in your guild to avoid the
shit-kicking of a lifetime so what do
you do well if you're like Ben Schultz
and his friends you might stage an epic
fail and inadvertently spawn one of the
Internet's originally - ultimately we
were gonna be recording and posting a
video of something and so the whole
dungeon was a screw around situation but
this was pretty good but I wouldn't say
it was like we wrote a script the day
before or anything like that it was
definitely we got to the spot that kind
of happened we thought it was hilarious
and we did another cake all running
first I will use them two names shout to
kind of scatter them so we want to fight
a whole bunch of them at once he was
pretty good plan and we should go pull
it off this time what do you think of
Bill can you give me a number crunch
real quick uh yeah give me a sec I'm
coming up with thirty two point three
three repeating of course percentage of
survival a lot better than we usually do
oh my god he just went in goddamnit
Leroy I'm down for him down we know you
were just stupid to tell me five chicken
in May 2005 the pals for life guilds a
rough go was first uploaded to Warcraft
movies comm and later YouTube the video
blurred the lines between a serious
attempt at a raid gone wrong and an
obvious gag between friends and it had
something for everyone the inside
baseball gibberish jokes I'm coming up
with thirty two point three three
repeating of course percentage of
survival a quotable and now iconic
phrase being shouted in revelry and jest
and of course senseless poultry worship
revived chicken it wasn't long before a
rough go quickly became the most watched
video on Warcraft movies and within
months it had racked up millions of
views on YouTube wait a second why is
the most viewed Leroy Jenkins upload on
a youtube channel dedicated to weird ass
GTA for kids videos you know what forget
I asked after the video went viral the
pals for life were bombarded by
thousands upon thousands of random
people looking to play with the
legendary Leroy well it was great in
some regards cuz we didn't get some
actual good players saying hey you guys
recall was hanging out with PvP with
them they were really good and create
that's pretty strong guild we do high
end raid got them then yeah I had a
stalker who I mean you call him a stock
it was just a guy who always followed me
around once I logged on you can always
tell if someone's logged on because you
can add them as a friend doesn't be
mutual and he would find me and do
whatever I was doing and asked if he
could join the guild and then do that
for weeks at a time your stalker
I know stalker look at me I'm wearing a
tuxedo
soccer's or we're like trench coats and
no underwear although Leroy Jenkins was
a popular meme within the mid-2000s
gaming scene it wasn't long before it
escaped the confines of the internet
making its first appearance on an
episode of college jeopardy and then
again later that year as a subtle
reference in a wow themed episode of
South Park okay right behind Stan can
you get ready to turn on true shot aura
at that moment I will use intimidating
shout I will use including shout and
while a South Park joke might be the
strongest sign that a meme has gone
mainstream you know something's truly
gone out of control when the US military
embraces it for Brett and his men each
trip into combat starts with an alarm
the meme has even become a way of
ridiculing poor warfare tactics not for
just in-game battles but real-life ones
too anyway despite the minor celebrity
status that Leroy Jenkins afforded
Schulz it's important to remember that
it was a 2005 level of Internet family
twitch didn't exist yet and the era of
gamers as money-making personalities was
still years away naturally once Leroy
Jenkins took off the pals for life tried
to create and sell merchandise around
the meme but with copyright laws being
what they are that didn't last for long
yeah we kind of thought maybe we should
bring up some shirts other people who
are bringing up shirts there was a lot
of shirts I mean people like why did you
go around stuffing like I think the only
people who I could have maybe talk to
would have been Penny Arcade but they
were licensed with Polly at the time so
they had art assets that we couldn't use
and glue made some shirts with me
drinking a 40 on it essentially that's
where Lee already came from but doesn't
inside joke no one got so we didn't sell
many while Ben and his guild drifted
away from Wow around 2007 the joke they
created as drunk college kids continued
to thrive in their absence all right
chunks let's do this Barney
kicking
[Music]
that point all bets are David you stick
it clean
oh Jesus goddamnit Leroy he would break
out god
there's a dude right now watching TV
that just had to change his pants in
response to its growing popularity
Blizzard created Leroy Jenkins action
figures and began implementing Schultz's
fictional character into their gaming
universe Leroy ended up with his own
closer card in hearthstone distinguished
by its high burst damage and aggressive
nature but true to his character it's
time on the battlefield was often
short-lived in WoW Blizzard even added
the community symbol as a garrison
follower which left Schulz feeling
conflicted they actually put Leroy in
the game at one point and that's about
when I quit whereas I you know what I
can't do anything about this it
basically just stole stuff not stole
they own any video you make with their
stuff as part of the end License
Agreement and I was just kind of
disappointed that I was in there and
they had someone voice it and it wasn't
me so I was like I'm done but after
reconnecting with Blizzard Schulz was
flown out to their studio where he was
paid a day's wage to rerecord his iconic
lines which were later added to both
games and when it came out that Warcraft
would be getting the big-budget
Hollywood treatment in 2016 many fans
Schulz included thought Leroy Jenkins
would get a cameo or at least the
passing reference and he did sort of in
the original draft of the script
screenwriter Gary Whitta had a private
Jenkins prematurely run in the battle
yelling a war cry and getting killed
almost immediately and although the
reference ended up being excluded from
the film's final cut Schulz was invited
to its red-carpet premiere where he got
to meet some surprisingly big admirers
but yeah Jamie Lee Curtis was fun they
told her I was there and she wanted to
meet me into the aisle with me and I was
excited to meet her when I heard that
too
I got a surprise for you though
alright John let's do this Leroy whether
you think it's funny or not there's a
certain charm to the Leroy Jenkins meme
because it encapsulates the last gasp of
an innocent Internet era that no longer
exists from the god-awful mic quality to
the vanilla version of wow that Schultz
and his friends were playing Leroy
Jenkins resonates in nostalgia that all
gamers can relate to know I think it's
great that people love it that much and
it has just become its own entity
it just gets referenced all these places
and it's kind of fun it's been 14 years
and so I think sometimes these
references get people like you to be
like a a leader or thing would be cool
and kind of like recycled self so I
could keep doing fun stuff
but on top of that Leroy Jenkins is a
cautionary tale stick to the game plan
and don't be a [ __ ] hero
it's a tragic parable about what it
means to be a teammate and not being
selfish you [ __ ] kidding me Matt are
you kidding me I'm trying to do my lines
and you're already eating your lunch
you're the worst cameraman ever yeah
usually it's the South Beach
[Music]